hey what's up everyone its Warren and
there's a lot of talk right now about a
huge spoiler from Mark Ruffalo about
Avengers endgame this is actually an old
spoiler Mark Ruffalo dropped this over a
year ago I actually did a video on this
before infinity war came out because at
first everybody thought that this
spoiler was for Avengers infinity war
but really it was for avengers endgame
and recently it's resurfaced and that's
why everybody is talking about it right
now so I'll go ahead and break it all
down for you in this video quick
reminder that I started a new giveaway
if you would like to enter for your
chance to win five imax tickets to go
see avengers endgame or Captain Marvel
in theaters all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel with the
notifications turned on like the video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain so over a year ago in an
interview with USA Today Mark Ruffalo
talked about the Hulk and Rocket Raccoon
becoming best friends in a movie
originally people thought it was
Avengers infinity war more on that in a
second what Mark Ruffalo said in the
interview was all of the universe coming
together is just a sight gag within
itself it's a very funny relationship
that the two of them have first of all
it's the biggest superhero and the
smallest just keeping them in a frame
together is a feat and hilarious in
itself so Mark Ruffalo says that the
Hulk and Rocket Raccoon will have a
relationship in Avengers end game the
reason this will happen in avengers
endgame is because we did not see it
happen in Avengers infinity war everyone
thought we would see it in Avengers
infinity war because again this
interview is over a year ago it was
actually before Avengers infinity war
came out into theaters which is why
everyone thought we would see it in
infinity war but we didn't which means
it's going to be in Avengers endgame so
here's the deal remember that the cast
and crew shot Avengers infinity war and
Avengers end game at the same time the
actors were never given full scripts and
even when they did get some scripts they
ended up being fake sometimes so a lot
of them didn't really know which scenes
were going into which movies or if the
scenes would even be in either movie at
all the recent others confirmed that the
only one who got a full real script was
Benedict Cumberbatch who plays Doctor
Strange so
Mark Ruffalo shot scenes with rocket but
he didn't know that it wasn't going to
be an infinity war so what does this
mean for a vengers endgame well right
now knowing the status of the Avengers
after the snap we know that both rocket
and Bruce Banner are at the Avengers
facility and they're the two smartest
people there remember Rockets a genius
so there are many ways that he can help
the Avengers more likely than not he
will help track down Tony Stark because
Tony Stark is in the Benatar rocket ship
if anybody knows how to track down the
ship its rocket he could also help with
the quantum realm suits as well but Mark
Ruffalo did say that we would see the
biggest hero and the smallest he wrote
next to each other so this means that
rocket and the Hulk fight alongside each
other at some point in time in Avengers
endgame which I have to admit will
probably be a really awesome scene so
that's it for the spoiler that Mark
Ruffalo dropped about Avengers end game
let me know what you think about the
Hulk and Rocket Raccoon teaming up in
the movie let me know in the comments
down below and again don't forget to
subscribe comment and like the video so
you can enter the giveaway and stay up
to date on everything relating to
Avengers in game as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]